[Norvig] This homework assignment has to do with games that have more than 5 cards.
So in games like 7-Card Stud or Texas Hold 'em, players have more than 5 cards.
Sometimes some of those cards are in common--
that is, all players share some of the cards. But that doesn't matter.
What you're asked to write in this program is this function best_hand,
which takes a hand with 7 cards in it and returns the best 5 card hand.
So in other words, each player out of their 7 cards has to come up with
the best hand that they can make according to the hand_rank.
What I want you to do is write your code for the function best_hand
to return a 5 card hand that's the highest ranked.
And here are some tests.
I'll give you a hint, which is a lot of the functionality can be found
in the preexisting Python modules.
One thing that's interesting to look at is the itertools module.